Now ladies and gentlemen turn your
attention to the rafters as we welcome
our 12th member to this illustrious
group of Laker Legends
join us right now in unveiling Powell
Gasol's number 16.
in three
two one
[Music]
thank you
and Now ladies and Gentlemen let's all
welcome and newest Laker Legend number
16 the great power Gasol
[Music]
thank you
thank you so much thank you so much what
a what an unbelievable feeling what an
unbelievable honor
I'll start to thank Vanessa
thank you so much for the video for the
introduction
I think you are here in the building
thank you for being here I know
I can't believe to tell her how much it
means to me uh I love you sister I'm
proud to be your brother I'm proud to be
an uncle to your lovely girls
thank you
I mean looking around I'm oh geez sister
I love you
love you
uh
man I'm just overwhelmed to see all the
faces here all of you
uh everyone that is here in the building
everybody was watching from home just
want to say thank you for making me feel
so special it's really been my honor to
wear these jerseys to play for these
franchise to help this team
to contribute to this city
it really has
so I thank you
but I can't go on without talking about
the person in the face that I don't see
ah the brother that elevated me inspired
me challenged me to be a better player
just to be a better man overall
I miss him I miss him so much like many
of us do I love him I wish he was here
with Gigi I really do
but I think he'll be proud
and he was looking forward to this
moment so
I love you brother
as a as a kid growing up in Spain I had
a dream I wanted to become a basketball
player play in the NBA I never in a
million years could think that a day
like this could have come such a huge
honor being amongst those great
individuals in this amazing franchise so
it just tells you that you know it's
just never said any limitations to your
what you can do what you can achieve
just push put in the work push yourself
every day be the best that you can be as
we know Mamba mentality
it seems it seems like it was yesterday
when we were here
on that game seven beating the Celtics
what a night what a day to remember
I'll never forget it I think you won't
either
um
and I want to thank
my family my parents
my brothers thank you so much for being
here
thank you for inspiring me for guiding
me supporting me throughout my life for
loving me I love you guys so much
[Applause]
I'm one of the luckiest men in the world
one of the main reasons because I
married a fantastic and amazing woman
and my wife Catherine
I love you baby
thank you so much for our two amazing
children that I love so deeply
um
and this couldn't happen without my
other family the Lakers family obviously
uh thank you Dr Buss father Genie for
for the vision your family Genie for
everything that you do you're amazing I
love you Linda as well you guys are
incredible uh you know
Rob my brother thank you for being here
tonight as well uh Mitch cup check thank
you for the opportunity
Phila Jackson
failure one of a kind
you know that we all know that uh I love
you thank you for encouraging your
players to read thank you for
introducing me and us to mindfulness I
love you to death I love you and all
your family to my teammates
you know there are years man
you can't thank you enough for elevating
me for embracing me for taking me in or
making me a better player
I hope that you feel that
a piece of that Jersey out there is
yours because it is
the coaching staffs the training staff
everyone in the organization thank you
uh you guys make what we do out here
possible to the city of La to Lakers
Nation
I love you
I love you deeply I love you forever
thanking you from thanking me making me
feel so special it's been an honor it
truly has Lakers
[Applause]
gracias
to all the media thank you uh for
everything that you guys do we're able
to reach millions of people because of
you thank you
I'm joining a very special group of
people amongst the Laker family
it's an immense honor I truly cherish it
and thank you thank you
thank you guys really I love I love you
thank you thank you so much and I'll
just I'll just finish with one thing you
know too much to those who much is given
much is expected and I will continue to
commit my life to impacting others to
making a difference too inspiring to
helping others to making this world a
healthier and better place I love you
all thank you thank you
thank you for August all
you are now immortalized your jersey is
retired ladies and gentlemen number 16 a
great pow Gasol